now we're not exactly sure when the
daily mail which some of us used to make
fun of started breaking more real news
than the washington post in the new york
times that's clearly the case now
and if you don't read it check it out
and you'll see that's true
daily mail reported last week on
messages between hunter biden and an
assistant who apparently has been tied
to the intelligence services of china
those messages included advice for joe
biden's 2020 presidential campaign we
want to go right to the reporter who
broke that story tonight
josh boswell who's got more for us josh
thanks so much for coming on congrats on
the story by the way
quite a story i wonder why it fell to a
foreign news source to report this
daily mail being a british publication
but but thank you for doing it so what
what do these messages tell us so these
emails and text messages that i found on
hunter biden's laptop
really quite intriguing um to set the
backdrop for you you've got hunter biden
in 2017 striking up this joint venture
with a chinese
oil and gas huge company um cefc
it's called now he enters into this
joint venture the secretary-general of
that country is
uh of that company sorry is a guy called
patrick ho
and uh and then hunter gets assigned
this uh
this assistant jackie bao she's a
chinese-american she was 29 at the time
and you see at first some very normal
messages
any any kind of personal assistant would
send doctors appointments
hotel bookings flight bookings but then
they get to to become more and more
personal
and the turning point really is when you
see patrick hoe
uh that secretary general of cefc get
arrested
by the feds um here in the united states
uh in november 2017 over bribery
corruption
charges and this assistant starts
sending hunter
these emails asking what's going on she
wants detailed information
on the case um kind of strange for for
someone in quite a junior position
and then you see more and more personal
emails come out as well
she um she jokes with him she uh tells
him that um you know the drinks are on
her
she she says that she's become very
close to him and she ends up
with his military dog tags in her new
york apartment we're not sure
why how they got there but um there is a
real closeness and then
as time goes on uh after this joint
venture starts to collapse because
of this arrest of patrick hoe and also
rest in in china
of um the um the leader of the company
the chairman
um you see her emailing hunter with
all of these strange ideas she she sends
him um a bunch of essentially opposition
research
to help joe biden in his presidential
bid
and it's very odd for that to be coming
from a 29 year old secretary
yeah maybe it was coming from somewhere
else amazing story
thank you for that josh boswell the
daily new mail appreciate it hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else